the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
right so I want to thank you all for
coming as the holiday season comes along
here I'm guessing that our people are
getting distracted with other things so
a little bit more of an intimate setting
today so heard people take advantage
that ask questions it's often a lot
easier to do when there aren't as many
people in the room so it's when we
encourage you to do that so let's get
right into this all right
fortunately the mic actually doesn't
pick that up at all as muster but but it
you all can hear the drilling above yeah
all right so this is lecture four kind
of went out of order to get our special
Halloween lecture in last time but we're
gonna be talking a little bit more about
the analysis of what we call structured
data and we're doing more structured
type analyses on instruction on
unstructured data again the course is
signal processing on databases this is
where we bring the ideas of detection
theory and apply them to the kinds of
data we see in databases strings and
other types of things there and so this
lecture is going to talk a little bit
more about we're gonna get to a little
bit more sophisticated analytics I think
up to this point we've done fairly
simple things basic queries using the
technology
pretty pretty simplest correlations
pretty simple stuff now we're gonna
begin to kind of go a little bit more
sophisticated and some of the things we
do and again I think as things get more
complicated
the d4m technology becomes it's its
benefits become even more apparent so so
just gonna get right into this you know
gonna show you are very generic schema
gonna talk a little bit more about some
of the issues that we encounter when we
deal with particular databases of the
database we're gonna be using for this
course is called accumulo and so I'll be
talking about some issues that are more
accumulo specific so a Camilo is a
triple store and and so the way we read
data into our triple store is using what
we call this exploded
Transpo's pair schema so we have
mastership we have an input data set
that might look like a table like this
with maybe our row key it's gonna be
somehow based on time and then we have
various columns here which may or may
not contain various data and then the
first thing we do is we basically
explode because our triple stores can
hold an arbitrary number of columns and
can add columns dynamically without any
without any cost we explode this the
schema by appending you know our column
1 and its value together in this way we
then just took a value it could be
anything of like 1 anything that we
wouldn't want to search on and then we
have a row key here I'll get into back a
little bit why we've done the row key in
this way and so by itself this doesn't
give us any real advantage but in
accumulo or any other triple store and
Orang just in D form associative arrays
we can store the transpose of the table
which means that all these columns are
now rows and this particular database is
a row oriented database which means it
can look up any row key with constant
access so we can look up row keys very
quickly and d4 am allowed we hide this
from you so that whenever you do inserts
it does you know if you want it to
happen it will store the transpose for
you and so you look like you have a
giant table where you can look up any
row key or any column key very very
quickly and makes it very easy to do
very complicated analytics one little
twist here that you may have noticed is
that I have flipped the this time field
here and taking it from essentially a
little endian and made it big endian and
I've always been an advocate of having
row keys that have some meaning in them
sometimes in in in databases they just
create sort of arbitrary random hashes I
think we have enough random data
the world that we don't necessarily need
to create more and so if we can have
meaning and our Okies I think it's it's
very useful because it just makes it
that much easier to debug data that
actually has meaning and so I've often
advocated for creating having a roki be
a time like key I think it's good to
have timeline keys and by itself there's
nothing wrong with having a little
endian roki except when you go parallel
if this database is actually running on
a parallel system you can run into some
issues people have run into issues which
is why I now advocate essentially doing
something else you know with the RO key
more like this in particular
Akemi low like many databases when it
goes parallel it takes the tables and it
splits them up and it splits them up by
row keys so it creates contiguous blocks
of row keys on different processors if
you have a little endian time Roky it
means every single insert will go to the
same processor and that will create a
bottleneck and then what will happen
over time it will then migrate that data
to the other processor so it can be a
real bottleneck if you have essentially
a little endian row key if you have a
big-endian row key if it just uses it
will then break up these things and then
when you insert your data it will sort
of naturally just cause that to spread
out over all the systems so that is if
your data is coming in in some kind of
time order which you know happens we
definitely see people coming in that you
know yesterday you know today's data
comes in today and tomorrow's data comes
in tomorrow you don't want to have it
all that data just hitting one processor
or one compute node in your in your
parallel database other databases have
more sophisticated distribution things
they can use a sort of a
a round-robin or a modular type of you
know they'll create a hash that does a
modular so that it doesn't have that
eliminates that type of hotspot but for
now we just recommend that people use
use this this does make it difficult to
use the row key as your actual time
value and so what you would want to do
is also stick have a have a column
called time that had the actual time in
it and then you could actually directly
look up in time in that way so so so
that's just a little nuance there good
sort of design feature probably
something that you wouldn't run into for
quite a while but we've definitely had
people hey I went off and implemented
exactly the way you exceed and but now
I'm going parallel you see this
bottleneck and I'm like oh so I'm going
to try and correct that right now and
tell people that this is the right way
to do it so starting out simple we're
just going to talk about kind of one of
the simplest analytics you can do which
basic getting basic statistical
information from your data set so if
this is our data set now we have a bunch
of you know row keys here time like with
some additional stuff to make them
unique unique rows and then we have
these various columns here some of which
are the gray ones are I'm saying are
filled in and the white ones are empty
and so what I want to do is just grab a
chunk of of rows okay and then I'm gonna
compute basically how many times each
column appears essentially some I'll sum
by type so I'll show you how we can sort
of look at we wanted to compute just how
many entries there were in column one or
for column two computing the covariance
computing type empirical variances are
all different things that we can do so
I'm going to do all those statistics on
the next slide all those analytics which
if you were to do them in another
environment would actually be you would
write a fair amount of code but here we
can do them and then each one of them is
essentially a one-liner so here's my set
of row keys okay
just created a list of RO keys that have
essentially a comma as the the separator
here there
okay and this is our table T so in the
notation we often just refer table T
this isn't a binding to an accumulate a
below or it could be any table really
any any any database that we support and
so this this line if this little bit of
code here says return me all the rows
given by this list of rows here and all
their columns so we're using the MATLAB
notation colon means return all the
columns this will then return these
results in the form of an associative
array now since the values of that are
strings in this case may be strings of
values of one we have this little
function here called double Logie which
will just basically say ignore whatever
the value is and just make it if it's
got an entry give it a 1 or otherwise
ignore it so this is a shorthand for for
it basically does a lot to Condesa
logical and then it does a double so we
can do map on it so this is our query
that gets us our rows and returns them
as an associative array with numeric
values we then compute the column counts
so that's just a MATLAB some command
which says basically this tells you the
the the dimension that's being
compressed so it's compressing the first
dimension which the rows so it's
basically collapsing it into a row
vector so it's just summing so that just
would tell us now we could then for all
those rows count how many occurrences of
each unique column of each column type
there was and then we can then get the
covariance the type type covariance by
just doing a transpose a or or square in
these do the same thing this is usually
slightly faster but not not a lot and so
that just does us the column type column
type covariance very simple and then
finally we have this function which
essentially undoes our
exploded schema so let's say we wanted
to return it back to the original dense
format where we have essentially four
columns column one two three and four
and we wanted the value put back into
the value position so we have this
function call to type with this and I
don't know if the name makes sense or
not but that's what we called it uh-huh
and basically it just says oh this is
the limp delimiter so it takes each one
of those splits it back out and stuffs
it back in and so then you now have that
associative array you can then do a sum
again on that to just get like I want to
know just how many column one instances
column two instance column three is
their work and likewise just doing a
transpose a or square in would then do
the covariance of that and that would
tell you of those higher-level types how
many there are were so this is a lot of
high-level information really highly
recommend that people do this when they
first get their data because it really
uncovers a lot of bad data right from
the get-go you'll discover columns that
are just like wow these two column types
never appear together and that doesn't
make sense there's something wrong there
or why is this column you know exploded
column why is it so common when that
doesn't make sense you know so again
it's very very useful for for doing
things and we always recommend people
start with this this analytic so again
that's very simple stuff we've talked
about it before let's talk about some
more sophisticated types of analytics
that we can do here so I'm gonna build
what I call a data graph so this is just
a graph in the data it may not actually
be a real you may have some other graph
in mind but this is the data supports as
a particular kind of graph in it so what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna set a
couple of starting column here okay C 0
that'll be our set of starting columns
okay and we're gonna set a column a sort
of allowed column types so we're gonna
be interested in certain column types
and we're gonna create a set of clutter
columns these are columns that we don't
want to we want to ignore you know we
want to we they're they're they're
either very very large or whatever and
so the basic algorithm is that we're
gonna get all the the column all the all
the we're gonna get all column or a
result it's gonna be called c1 here okay
and that's gonna be all rows in c0 that
have are of type C T and excluding
columns C L so this is a rather
complicated join type of thing that
people often want to do you know they
want to do these types of things look I
want to get all these rows but I only
care about these particular types of
columns and I don't really care about I
want to expressively eliminate certain
clutter columns that I know are just
like always pointing everywhere so let's
let's go look through the d4m code that
does this sort of complicated type of
join okay so I'm gonna specify my c0
here and this could be a whole list it
doesn't it's just it could be a whole
list of of starting columns I'm gonna
specify my column types and in this case
I'm gonna have two column types I'm
gonna say create a string called starts
with which since it creates a column
range one column range around column one
and run a column range around column
three and then I'm gonna specify a
clutter column here which is which is
just this a and again it could be a
whole list as well alright so step one
here is is I'm gonna pass I'm assuming
that this table is bound to one of these
exploded transposed pairs so it will
know when I give it columns to look up
to then point to the correct table
so we have a c0 here and it will it will
say all right please return all rows you
know all the data that contains c0
basically all those rows I'm then gonna
say now just I just I don't care about
their values I just want the rows so
this is an associative array and this
command row just says just give me those
rows so basically I had a column I
returned all the rows but now I just
want the row keys I'm now gonna take
those row keys and pass them back into
the row position so now I will have
gotten all the entire row so basically I
got a column I took those rows and now
I'm going and striping and painting and
getting the whole rows so now I have
every single and since I don't care
about the actual values I just want them
to be numeric okay I just I just I just
use the double Logie command so
basically i've done a rather complicated
little piece of query here in terms of
get me all columns that contain all rows
that contain a certain column and so
that's now an associative array and then
going to reduce to specific allowed
column so I'm gonna pass in I'm gonna
say please give me just the ones of
these particular column types so I got
the whole row but now I just want to
eliminate those I could have probably
actually put this in here but whether
it's more efficient or not to do it here
here it's six of one half dozen the
other I try and make my table queries
just either only columns or only rows it
tends to make things simpler so so now
we do that we have just those types and
now I want to eliminate the clutter
columns so I have a which is just of
these type and I want to then eliminate
any of the columns that you know of the
container in this basically column one
so I had column one was one of my types
but I don't care about that and so I can
just do subtraction I can just basically
say Oh
go get the clutter columns and subtract
them from the data that I have and now
I'm just gonna get those columns all
right and I have now the set of columns
I now have c1 so I've completed the
analytic I just described in the prevail
on either sophisticated analytic I could
then proceed to look for additional
clutter for instance I could then
basically query say please give me those
those stick the c1 back in and then sum
it up and look for things that had a lot
of values and continue this process this
is an example of something they might
want to do when I have this data set so
these show you the kinds of kinds of
things more sophisticated analytics that
you can do I want to talk a little bit
about data graphs in terms of what are
the things you can do here what is
supported the topology of your data
remember this this this edge list has
direction when you have graphs they can
very well have edges that have a
direction and a lot of Palatine people
say well I want to get the whole graph
I'm like well if you're doing
essentially things that are based on
breadth-first search you're not you may
not be able to get the whole graph
because you're never going at it from
the right correct direction so you are
definitely limited by the natural
topology of your data so for example
here let's say I start with c0 is column
1 a so I now have essentially this
vertex a let's call it and now here I
say okay I now want to get all give me
the whole row of all of all I'm gonna do
give me all the rows that you know the
rows and contain that all right so then
these two guys pop up so I get another a
and I get a B so I got a B here that's
good and then I'm gonna go proceed go
down again I'm like all right I'm gonna
then now say all right give me all the
rows that contain those columns
oops and I go down again right and I got
and I got the see did I get a see no I
never got to see I never got to see in
any one of these you know even though
it's all in the date and probably all
connected and I never actually got a
seat so oh there I got the seat now when
I did the second time
I got the seat there we go so this is an
example of a series of breadth-first
searches that result in getting the
whole graph of but the graph had this
topology and and and would naturally
admit that so certainly in this
particular case the data and the queries
were good for this with what we call a
stark because essentially it's a vertex
with everything going into it let's take
a different graph this is what we call a
cycle so we see a little cycle here
going like this we start again with a
let me get our columns and get C ones
across here and and that's kind of the
end of the game you know we get A's we
get a B what we're not gonna get
anything else when we call them back up
they're not gonna get anything else and
so we're basically stuck here at B we
weren't able to get to C or D so these
are kind of little more subtle things
than one has to worry about and and once
you see it it's kind of all of course I
can't do I'm not gonna get the whole
graph but you'd be amazed at how many
teenage girls like I wanted the whole
graph and I just can't do it it's like
well you don't have the edges going in
the right direction you know for you to
do that you're gonna have to think
things through a little bit more so I
just wanna it's kind of a little catch
that I want to point out to people
because it's something that people can
run into
we're gonna do a little a different type
of analytic here I've changed some of my
columns here have some gonna be let's
call these coordinates I'm gonna have
now with my data set an X and a
y-coordinate that I'm storing in
different rows and columns I want to do
some kind of space windowing I want to
find all data within a particular x and
y a coordinate all right so I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna select a set of data here
are sort of rows and I'm gonna give a
space polygon and I'm gonna you know
query those get the get the get the data
and then I'm gonna extract the space
coordinate from from the values there
and we return all columns that are
within our my space space window here
and again this is good for finding all
those in between your space window um if
you're concerned that you're gonna be
getting an awful lot of like if you have
like a let's say of a coordinate that
goes through New York you know and
you're concerned that that's just gonna
you don't want to get you don't want New
York but you happen to be on the same
latitude or longitude New York you can
do something called Merton ization which
basically is essentially imagine taking
your strings of your coordinates and
interleaving them and now you've
essentially created a an ascii based
grid of the entire planet and so that's
a way of sort of you want to quickly
filter down you can get a box and then
go back and do the detailed coordinates
to vent yourself from having to do so
that's a standard trick and there's
variety of Merton ization schemes that
people use for interleaving coordinates
in this way I think Google Earth has a
standard box now as well I find this the
simplest because you literally just take
the two strings and and interleave them
and if you have a spate you can actually
then do with variable precision because
of like if you just like a space I don't
know it all kind of works out pretty
nicely and you can read the coordinate
right there you know like the first one
is the FIR you know and you can even
clued the plus and minus signs for a lot
of commodity
so you know maybe not the most efficient
a scheme but one that's human readable
I'm a big advocate of human readable
types of types of data schemes all right
so let's actually do that analytic so
again so I created my got selected my
ROS got my X&Y coordinates in those rows
and then figured out which columns they
were that it satisfied them alright so
let's do that now in code here so we
have the alright so so we have I gave it
a in this case I gave it a row range so
you can do this is what a range query
looks like do you give any either an
associate array or a table something
that is a triple essentially that's a
string : and another string it will
treat that as a range query and we
actually support doing if you have
multiple sets of triples it will it will
it should handle that so which is good
I'm gonna specify my bounding box here
essentially a box and I happen to do
with complex numbers just for fun just
because complex numbers is a night way
to store you know coordinates on a
two-dimensional plane and MATLAB
supports them very nicely complex
numbers are our friends so there you go
but I could have just as easily had a
set of x and y vectors so I'm gonna get
all the rows so I query that very good
we have that and then so that just gives
me that set of data all those rows I
then I use my starts with my x and y ok
to get just the columns of those X's and
Y's and I'm now gonna convert those
exploded schema back into a regular
table with with this call to type
function so that basically takes those
values so it takes those coordinate
values so like we saw it takes these
coordinate values here okay like the 0 1
and it puts it back into the value
position and then so now I have though
it will still be a string in the value
position which our associative arrays
can handle fine but I now want to really
treat it like a number so we just have
overloaded the standard MATLAB string to
numb function which will convert those
strings and will store them back you've
now have an associative array with
numbers in them so we call this a XY and
now we can do something we basically can
extract the X values here so we have a
XY and say all right give me the X
column and then a XY and give me the Y
column and then MATLAB has a built-in
function called in polygons which you
give it a polygon so I give it the real
and the imaginary parts of our my
polygon here s and the x and y
coordinates and we'll return in you know
essentially the value of is that is that
in there and which is group which is
great because you know there are many
dissertations written on the in polygon
problem and it's nice that we have a
nice built in a MATLAB function to do
that and then now I have that and I can
just pass that back into the original a
so I do find so this actually returns a
logical of zeros and ones if I do find
then that will return a set of indices
and I just passed those indices back
into a and then I can get those columns
and there we go all very standard and
MATLAB like syntax again this is a
fairly complicated analytic if you were
doing this using other Technic
technologies I mean I'm sure all of us
would be writing a fair amount of code
and this is just the kind of thing that
we can do very easily in d4m another
analytic which is probably a bit of a
stretch but I was just having fun here
is doing convolution on strings which is
a little odd
but I gave it I gave it a whirl so so
what we want to do is we want to
convulse some of our data with a filter
I mean come bobbing with filters as a
standard type of thing so it's a
standard way we use do detection here
and so the way we do that is once again
I'm setting a I give a list of rows that
I want here I'm gonna create a filter
which is just essentially a box of you
know for essentially a four wide box so
I get my rows all right and then I
convert them to numeric and I'm gonna do
my convolution on the X columns okay so
let's see here so I'm gonna get these
I'm getting and basically on getting all
the x coordinates all right I'm gonna
sum all of those okay so I basically now
have all those alright and now I'm going
to pop those back in to their values and
now I can do a convolution and this
convolution works if one of the axes is
sort of like an integer sequence type of
thing so you can do you know it tries to
extend that naturally so something to
play around with you know if you want to
do convolutions we've sort of supported
and I'm sure if anyone have used do play
with round it would be glad to hear your
experiences think about how we should
extend it so these are all sort of basic
standard first-order statistical
analytics that one can do on data sets
and we can support them very very well
let's do some more complicated what I
would call second-order analytics all
right so I'm gonna do something called
it's a it's a complicated join
essentially what I call a type pair so
what I want to do here is I want to find
all row
that contain values of that habit that I
want to find rows that have both a value
of type 1 and of type 2 so I'm going to
specify this to be you know basically X
to be type 1 and Y to be type 2 and I
want to find all data that you know has
has entries in both those very so very
standard type of join type of thing and
this is this is done a little bit more
complicated than we need it to be just
to show you kind of some of the richness
here you can kind of take a fork anyway
we could probably do this whole thing in
about two lines but but I'm sort of kind
of showing you some additional sort of
features of d4m in the in the spirit of
this analytic so again I'm just gonna
use a range query here so I have this
range I'm gonna have my type 1 be starts
with X and my type 1 to be starts with Y
so I do my query I convert all the
string ones to numeric ones and then
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna basically
all right get me get me all the columns
of type 1 all right
sum them all together find everything
that equals then and and I only care
about the ones that are exactly equal 1
so like I do if I had 2 X's I'm like no
I don't want those I want exactly 1 X in
this row alright and then I'm gonna take
those rows that have exactly 1 X ok I'm
gonna put pass them back into a so I now
just get the rows that that have exactly
1 X all right I'm gonna filter it again
with CT 1 and CT - I'll go done need to
do that all right and I'm going to sum
it again and now I'm gonna say all right
get me the only ones that are exactly 2
so I know my X is exactly 1 it's an
order for it to be exactly 2 that means
my Y also had to have only exactly one
entry in it so now I have the data that
just has exactly one of each of those
all right now I want to create sort of
like a cross correlation pair mapping of
this okay so I'm actually gonna look for
X's across columns that appear say I
want to look for X's that appear in more
than one in one with more than one Y or
a Y that appears with more than one X
this is a variety of ways to do that
here what I'm doing is so I I've gotten
the rows of a that have exactly one x
and y I now pass that back in to get my
seed my to get the X's again and one of
the things that we've done that's kind
of nice is we've overloaded the syntax
of this query on our associative arrays
and in our table queries such that if it
only has one argument it will return an
associative array but if you give it
three output arguments it will return
the triple so in this case the row the
column and the value an I don't care
about the the row and the value I just
care about the column but that's a nice
way we're often want to in certain cases
want to bump back and forth between the
triples in a representation and the
associative array implementation now you
always can use the fine command around
any associative array just as you can in
normal MATLAB or matrices and that will
return the triple the advantage of doing
it here is that when ie
is that it's faster because what we
actually do when we do the query
internally is we actually get the
triples and then convert it to an
associative array and if you just say I
want the triples we can just shortcut
that and give you the triples right away
so sometimes if you're dealing as a very
large associative arrays or some
operation that's just you know this is
this this I want to get some more
performance back then working especially
like if you're like well I only care
about one thing I don't care about all
of the values I don't really need to be
a full associative array then that's a
great way to to sort of short circuit
that so do that here and now we can
construct a new associative array which
is just taking the XS and the Y's and
creating a new associative array with
those all right and that just shows me
the correlation
you know between the XS and the Y's and
I can then find CT basically X's that
have more than one y so I just summed
them there or wise with more than one
axis again these are very similar to
Analects that people want to do and
again very simple to do and again
showing you some of the different types
of syntax that are available to you and
d4m again if you're used to using MATLAB
these types of tricks are very natural
we're just showing you they also exist
within within d4m so here's another one
so I wanted to find common pair set c 1
and c 2 and get all comms c 1 and c 2
and find the rows that have just one
entry in C 1 and C 2 and it basically
checks to see if data pairs are present
in the same row again something that
people often want to do you've got a
complicated type of joint so here we
have a set of columns 1 C 1 a set of
columns C 2 all right I want to create
this I want to sort of interleave these
together into a pair okay so I want to
create some concept of a pair and see we
have this function here called cat
string which basically will take two
strings and another delimiter and we'll
basically if they are have the same
number of strings we'll just in or leave
them together if one of these is just a
single string it will just end
essentially prepend or append that so
for instance you if you're wondering how
we actually create these exploded values
of like call 1 and B that's just
basically using this function here we
Ted we get the values we have the
columns we put the essentially the the
pipe thing in the middle and it just
merges them together so we now sort of
interleave these two together so we'll
not have something like call one b pipe
call 3 b pipe comma as the the separator
so now i can create a set of pair
mappings from c1 to its pairs okay
that's a 1 2 it's pairs and a 2 it's
pairs I can get the columns of the
a 1 and a 2 and then I can find all the
pairs by essentially through this
combination of matrix multiplies and
additions and etc so very sort of
complicated analytic done very nicely
and there's a whole bunch of different
ones you can do here these are almost
semantic extension the column types may
have several different types and you
want to do so for instance if I have a
pair of columns here column 1 and column
3 I could say well that also implies
this column 3 equals column 1 that's one
kind of sort of pair reversal type of
thing you'll have extensions you might
say look if I have a column 1 a that
also implies that really there should
also be a column 2 a and other types of
things like that so these are just types
of things that people do with pairs
they're often very useful and I think
that basically brings us to the end of
the lecture portion of the class so
again just the exploited schema really
allows you to do this very rapidly with
your data and you can implement very
efficient graph analytics as a sequence
of essentially row and column queries
because we use this very special
exploded transpose pair a schema and
increasingly as you become more and more
skilled with this you will discover that
many many many of your analytics really
reduced to matrix matrix multiplies that
matrix matrix multiply
really captures the full sort of
all-to-all correlation that you want to
do without having to kind of you know
figure things out alright so I'm now
going to go and show some not these
specific Analects but some analytics
that are more sophisticated based on the
Reuters data set if you remember a few
weeks ago we did we worked with the
Reuters data set and so let's see here
so we did we already did the enemy
analysis application a few weeks ago I'm
going to now do basically what happens
when you construct tracks which is a
more sophisticated structured analytic
and the assignment I'll send out was
basically doing more cross correlations
for those of you who have kept it going
here this far and continuing to do the
homeworks I'll send this homework out to
you which is basically just cross
correlating the data sets that you have
again and not a not an assignment that
really predispose requires you have
having done the previous assignments
just any data set you know pull it into
an associative array and then new matrix
multiplies to you know figure out the
cross correlations and what they mean
all right so with that why don't we take
a short five-minute break and then I'll
come back and show you the demo